the raids it's your second feature film
isn't it and it's a film that you made
in Indonesia and you actually became a
filmmaker when you went to Indonesia in
a way didn't you how did that happen
because you actually starts out in Wales
in oom yeah I mean I was basing where I
was 27 and I'd always wanted to get into
the film industry but I didn't actually
do enough to get myself noticed I did it
was my own fault I didn't push myself
and my wife who's Indonesian Japanese
she burned a few phone calls for some
family and friends back home and in
Indonesia and she spoke to like some
producers and then got me a directing
gig doing a documentary and that
documentary was about panchuk see that
so going out there and working on that
for six months that's the thing that
kind of you know that was the impulse
that led me to find out about this new
martial arts discipline that I'd never
seen before
introduce me to a choreography team
tradition and the culture that I could
draw upon for my first film ran'tao but
more importantly introduced me to eco I
studied actor of moranto and now the
raid tell us a little bit more about
this martial arts is very different
isn't it yeah Pentax see that is
actually indigenous to Indonesia and
it's there's over 200 different schools
of it in Indonesia alone some of them
borrow elements from like animal styles
so you have one called like seal and
Halima which is sort of Tiger style and
then they use like like a palm for the
for the hit and then the claw to kind of
pull back and bring you back in so it's
pretty aggressive it's not it's not it's
not the prettiest of things to see but
what I love about see light is that you
know it's very it's going Chuck step
position where I mean bears like the
lead up to an attack looks very graceful
and beautiful and then that moment of
impact becomes very ugly and very
aggressive and those things are really
instant to me and we through echo-y so
found like the perfect guy to kind of
you know to showcase that he has a very
unique approach to sort of like to his
to the movement of it where he seems to
understand how everything looks on
camera and that's a very rare skill for
a screen fighter to have them have you
had to see that yourself yeah I tried
not anymore
obviously but I tried for about like
nine to ten months there this is before
the first film I wanted to learn enough
so that I could be able to have a say in
some of the choreography but for the
guys who were doing the choreography to
know that it came from a place of
knowledge not just me sort of guess
working and saying hey try this elbow
try this kick maybe it looks right so I
had to feel like I knew
about see that and over the last few
years even if I'm not practicing it
because I spent so much time doing the
choreography with the guys I've learned
a lot more about it I've learned a lot
more about the character of it how it
looks and how it moves then he mentioned
a code Australia and he also it's a
course a star or the phone a brilliant
star at that but he also is doing the
choreography as well but some of it
wasn't he yeah Iko the the choreography
team basically for the rate consists of
myself Eko and yang Yang's a guy plays
mad dog and so the three of us would get
together and in before pre-production
even starts you have three months where
it's just the three of us inside a room
with a bunch of crash mats and handycam
and we designed every single fight scene
from beginning to end and on top of that
we also do a video storyboard so we
actually decide every single shot and
every single edit and map out the fights
in in real detail then in terms so we
can see we could pretty much tell how
it's going to look and usually that ends
up being 95% the same in final
production they're superfast this film
isn't it and it's super fast the action
in it I mean it's that because that's
what's in let's like or is that the kind
of star that you wanted to go for in the
film and how did what were the
challenges of shooting that it's a
combination of both really I mean I I
wanted it to be super fast and
aggressive but then also see that lends
itself to that too you know it's it's
forever adapting there's a martial art
you know it's like doesn't matter
whether in a wide-open space or like a
confined area their techniques and
disciplines which can help you in those
other situations
the difficulty we're shooting this one
of those things whereby how could say is
maybe it's a challenge and we kind of
set ourselves because I'm a huge fan of
like Jackie Chan movies from the 80s and
the 90s and and one of things I love
about the way he shoots action the way
he had its action is that you never get
this feeling like anything is shot just
for coverage sake you never get a
feeling that gets like a wide master
shot and and just over shoulders and
then find the Edit in post-production
every shot is I could jigsaw piece so
it's a very specific weekend in middle
and end of that shot and it's designed
in a way to kind of maximize the view
for the audience of what the detail in
our choreography is and so that becomes
like a challenge and because you know
we're always looking for what's that
right shot to show off this piece of
choreography you know is it still gonna
work from ready to edit and and yeah
that's that's like the biggest challenge
for us then
now obviously you spent a lot of time
kind of putting it together the
choreography so you had this video shots
and everything but I'm guessing that
even with all that preparation there's
still gonna be some injuries all during
the shooting tell us about that
unfortunately yeah from time to time we
get few injuries we try our best to kind
of like minimize it so we always have
you know we're pretty responsible we
have like ambulance crew on standby we
have paramedics massage therapists so we
have a bunch of people that in the
behind the scenes who were waiting in
case something goes wrong
and the way we designed our action
sequences and our stunts we we come up
with ideas which will make the audience
react in a big way but then we look for
the execution of it to be so safe where
it minimizes that injury then but
obviously it's impossible to do anything
without the possible threat of injury
and yeah we had a couple of ropey
moments where some people took a little
bit of a spill and we're before but
thankfully nobody was like seriously
hurt by then what was the worst thing
that happened the worst and this is the
one I can't tend to tell a lot my Q&A is
that we had one guy who gets flipped
over a balcony and in his back snaps in
half now that sounds bad in itself but
the way we executed it was there was
three different shots so the first one
is a big wide shot and we we had crash
mats in place we took the wall out and
then he's on a wire to control the path
of his fault so he flipped over boom
lands and crash man locked the camera
position put the wall back in lift him
one meter up drop him on his back so
that his legs couldn't come on one side
drop him on his bum so his back and come
down the other side so then his three
shots get stitched together make it look
like we've really thrown this guy over
and he's really snapped his back where
he went wrong and where it became the
injury was that when we did that first
shot with the first flip over the guys
who were control of the wire to make
sure his path was correct they pulled
him too hard so when he left over
instead of coming down nicely on an
angle he just went straight across and
hit the back of his head into a wall so
then they lost control of the wire and
he started to fall but because of the
bump it knocked him on a trajectory so
he ended moving away from the crash mats
and so his fall and it'll be in five
meters down on the concrete but yeah ten
minutes of being unconscious and then
the paramedics came in and checked on
him after that he woke up and the serve
you know okay let's go again yeah that
kind of think that macho thing the stunt
guys like to do but we kind of you know
we told him no you're not doing anything
yet you're gonna go to hospital first
and then we check up on you and then
four days later then he came back on set
and he did the stunt and yeah I know
everyone reacts big when they see that's
them so there's gonna be a sequel isn't
there can you tell us anything about
that okay the sequel we're gonna start
shooting in January next year it follows
on from the events of the first movie as
a continuation of Rama's story we're not
gonna stick to the same formula we're
not gonna make this something which is
set in one building this time we're
gonna take the story out on the streets
and actually expand it more and so yeah
we're ramping up the action sequences
because we feel like we need to kind of
do something bigger and better than the
first one and yeah other than that I
can't really say too much then cuz if we
spoil a heavy otherwise but yeah the few
remaining people that actually survived
the first one they'll come back in the
second one and there's also going to be
an english-language version isn't that
are you involved with that at all and
what you think about it yeah there's an
english-language version being made
there they haven't started production
yet the still in development at the
moment I'm on board as an exec producer
and so I'll have some say in some things
but not everything but I'm excited by it
I'm kind of like I'm flattered by it
really more first and foremost and I'm
excited to see what they do with it but
you know for it to work it has to be
someone fresh it has to be a new voice
and you know somebody who's gonna take
the initial storyline to it and see what
they can add and see what they can
change I figure what we gave was like a
very basic stripped-down concept but
there's lots of room for improvement
there's lots of things they can do
differently with it but as long as that
person who directs it gets given the
same creative freedom and flexibility
that I got given then there's no reason
why they can't do that so yeah I've got
high hopes for it but the best part for
us is that part of the agreement was
that they wanted Iko in the iron to do
the choreography some of the
choreography for the film so it means
that there's gonna be a Hollywood film
now which has see that as one of the
main sort of you know martial arts
disciplines in it and considering our
company exists not just to be a
commercial film company but to also
promote see that it couldn't be more
happy sir
we're really excited fantastic news and
finally obviously you've got the sequel
to do next but what would you be liking
to do what would you like to be doing
and say a couple of years time when once
that's all done and dusted
I love at some point my career I'd love
to go to make a Western it's like my
favorite genre and if I could do
something along the lines of the Wild
Bunch I'd be very very happy what about
just like a film that me and my dad
would watch all the time together
yeah we watched it on like TV VHS DVD
blu-ray 35 mil like we've seen in every
format we could possibly watch that film
so to be able to do something that enter
that genre would be fantastic so
hopefully a Western some kind time down
the line really well look forward to
that and very much looking forward to
the sequel of the raid as well good luck
with it go thank you very much
appreciate it is
you